so this is the talk called space AG
Miracle tools. JS uh everybody calls me
NJ because it's easier than trying to
pronounce my actual name so uh NJ it is
and I'm not web safe on Twitter and uh I
work uh at Adobe on a project called
brackets which I helped start uh
brackets is a code editor for web
developers and uh it's built almost
entirely in HTML CSS and JavaScript a
little native stuff around it so that it
can access the local file system uh and
it's completely open source uh MIT
license and stuff like that has anybody
here actually tried brackets out like oh
good has anybody ever actually tried to
hack on brackets or write an extension
for it all right you don't C
Brian I mean no you count a lot I just
mean okay so well maybe we can give it a
couple people so you know I called this
talk Space Age Miracle tools. JS which
is kind of a terrible name because how
could you possibly live up to a name
like that but what I'm going to show is
some sort of early experiments some
ideas we have for future developer
tooling and we kind of want your
feedback on you know whether these
things make sense whether there's
something that you think we or other
people should pursue um and then on top
of getting feedback on these ideas we
also want to hope hopefully Inspire
other people you know you guys to think
about what kinds of developer tools
would you like to see you know for the
next 10 years for the challenges that
we're going to be facing in the future
or even are facing now that maybe aren't
adequately addressed by the kinds of
tooling that we have
today so this is gonna be a sequence of
demos and I didn't actually do most of
them myself so I'm going to introduce
who actually worked on them so the first
one's called thesis and uh it's done by
Tom Liber uh who I think he's just
finishing an PhD at MIT uh and Joel
Brandt who works at Adobe in their
research group and the problem they're
trying to solve is that debugging
asynchronous code I mean we're web
developers right we have to deal with
this all the time and it's super fun
right right yeah so basically you know
you see something's wrong in your web
app and then you have to kind of guess
where the problem is by reading all your
code on the client maybe on the server
right it could be either place um and
then because the problem might be an
asynchronous code you can't just step
through all your code right you have to
uh think about every single place your
code might go and then like add break
points or log statements or whatever and
just sort of scatter them all over the
place and then like reload try to figure
out what's going on and then you know if
you haven't fixed it yet then you know
you kind of have to R and repeat so it's
kind of a pain in the ass
right so the idea of thes is to make it
easier to debug this stuff by basically
capturing information as we go along so
to see this let me go ahead and start at
brackets uh and if you haven't seen
brackets before you know as you can tell
it's pretty much looks like a text
editor on the surface right it's just
got the standard stuff you'd expect like
code coloring and it's got a little file
tree and stuff like that I'll show some
of the more like specific features that
we already have in Brackets later on but
right now you know and all this stuff is
built in HTML like I said uh in
JavaScript um but let me go ahead and
show you how this thesis stuff works so
uh let me start by starting the server
for it so this is my server app but what
I'm going to do is instead of starting
it in node uh I'm going to start it in
node thesis which is going to instrument
it in certain ways that we'll talk about
later okay so this is running my node
app now and then from brackets I'm going
to enable thesis and I'm going to go to
the source code for that um project oops
and I'm going to go into this live
development mode okay so now I'm running
this application and this is just like a
simple demo app it's a reservation
application right and so the idea is
you're supposed to be able to select an
activity you want to do and then select
which date you want to do it on but as
you can see there's no actual dates in
the dropdown right so there's a bug
somewhere so where's the bug well it
could be in this event handler for this
drop down right it could be that we're
not kicking off the Ajax request
properly it could be that on the server
side it's not accessing the database
properly or it's not returning the
response properly or whatever so it
could be in a bunch of different places
so because we were running this all in
the context of thesis we can actually go
back and look at our source
code and now I'm going to switch to my
client side JavaScript and you can see
that as I've been doing stuff uh it's
actually been capturing information on
which functions got called right and
this is live so if I go and I pick
another activity let's say um you know
like running or something you can see
that it updates what got called um so
that's kind of useful and I can also
click on these things to get more
information so for example we can see
that our change Handler got called two
times which is what we would expect
because we picked two different things
from the background yeah oh I'm
sorry is that
better yeah better is that
right okay so um you can see that we've
got a change make it even bigger so
we've got a change Handler here right
and that got called which is what we
expect and so I can click on that and
I'm sorry I can't increase the font size
of this right now but basically it's
showing the information about each of
those calls and I can also look at some
other stuff like there's this setup
dates function which got called also
twice and then there's an Ajax post and
then there was a call back function that
got returned or or that got called when
the uh data was returned right so I can
click on all those things and you can
see that we're actually showing in this
log now basically the causal chains here
so the change Handler called setup dates
and then as a result of the post that
got done in setup dates get dates called
back uh got called and the interesting
thing here I mean a little side note is
that you know this isn't just a call
stack right like this is basically a
call stack but the get dates call back
that actually got called back
asynchronously so if you were to look at
this in Dev tools you wouldn't see it in
the same call stack as all that other
stuff uh but we're actually kind of
tracking that stuff and showing you uh
how these asynchronous things are
related to each other so I can look at
this and I can look at the return values
from get dates call back and you can see
that the data I got back from the server
is empty right so clearly there's a bug
on the server so I'm going to switch to
the node code so this is the JavaScript
that's actually running on the Node
server and because we were running that
in this thesias thing too you can see
that um it's actually showing the same
uh instrumentation information for the
server side and again I can click on
these things to see what happens so I
can click on these calls here and I can
take a look and see oh okay well it
looks like this handle aiqu got called
and that called get dates but in get
dates this activity was undefined and so
if I look at the call to that it looks
like I just made like a stupid typo
right so this is obviously a very simple
example uh and this is kind of early
work but the idea is to make it so that
by sort of watching what your
application is doing we can give you
rich information that you can use for
debugging after the fact as opposed to
you having to sort of proactively figure
out all the places where you have to
essentially manually instrument your
code yourself with log statements and
and break points and all that kind of
stuff um so this is actually just turn
this off uh so they've they've uh
started putting this stuff up on GitHub
already so it's open source so uh if you
have brackets you can check out adob
research thesis and you can just install
this as an extension uh into brackets to
check it out and definitely give them
feedback on you know is this useful what
other kinds of information do you think
could be collected um you know what are
different ways you might want to query
that
information okay so that was thesis the
the second thing we're going to show is
this idea called instabug and this was
actually done by Peter Flynn who uh you
might have seen his talk me see his talk
on Wednesday on performance uh it's a
good talk uh you should check it out on
the recording if you didn't see it but
um anyway he's gonna talk about
something totally different now which is
called
instabug Almost There You Go can
everyone hear me all right cool
all right so um how many people have
seen this demo from Brett Victor a while
back um you have basically a code editor
on the left on the right hand side you
have this visualization of uh how the
values of variables change over time and
as you edit the code on the left the
visualization on the right hand side is
actually updating continuously as you're
typing so you're getting this sort of
live feedback how many people have seen
that that demo before all right cool um
this is the kind of uh sort of Novel
thinking that gets me really excited
about the future of of JavaScript
tooling
and so I've actually been working on
something along these lines uh and uh
I'll uh basically to to looking at some
of the ways that you can Branch out from
this idea so let me show you a bit of
that just going to take a little quick
switch of Route
here oh you already turned off these
okay so I don't know if I can make the
font much bigger than that to have it
still fit but hopefully that'll be
okay
um so for those of you who haven't seen
the demo here's basically how it works
you have some code uh and as you make
edits in the code actually see the stuff
on the right hand side here is updating
in real time and showing me how each
value changes uh as it's assigned as
it's modified so as I'm making edits
here you can actually see those values
being modified so uh what's really cool
about this is it's taking this
traditional three-step cycle that we're
used to First you write code then you
test code then you debug the code to
find problems to fix the problems it's
taking those three steps and it's fusing
them to this one continuous ongoing
process so while you're writing code
you're Contin ously seeing uh live
feedback as to the the results of
executing that code and when the result
isn't what you expected you already have
this Rich debug information on the
screen right right there um and I think
that's actually a combination of sort of
two interrelated ideas the first is this
this sort of idea of continuously
re-executing the code as you're making
changes and uh to be able to show you
that live feedback and then the second
is this really rich visualization you
see on the right hand side that's
broader on the time Spectrum than when
you get from a traditional debugger so
traditional debugger right you're
looking through this really Nar window
it's just an instant in time and that's
all you can see and you can step
forwards but you're only looking through
a little sliver this is showing you a
more holistic view of the the whole
history of the execution of of the flow
of execution through the code um and I
think that right hand side that
visualization can actually be uh made
semantically more rich in other ways too
um let me show you a couple ideas that
we had around
that uh so one thing you could do for
example is you can gray out blocks of
code that aren't being executed so your
eye is just naturally drawn toward the
actual code path that the execution took
then if you have something that uh let's
say a loop being executed we can show
you the uh number of iterations that it
executed just a really quick way to get
it you know wrap your head around what
the codee's been doing and then let's
say if you have a variable that's being
used as an index into an array we can
actually show you the value of that
variable not just as an integer sort of
floating out of context but actually as
an indicator on the array itself showing
you what member of the array that Valu
is actually pointing to so it's
basically beginning to give you sort of
this richer semantic view of of what the
values in the code mean and and what the
execution of the code looks like over
time um but skipping back to that first
thought the sort of continuous
re-execution of the code one question
about that is is whether that's actually
sort of a fatal flaw in this this whole
idea every time you see demos like this
it's always either a toy snippet of code
like this one or it's some kind of run
Loop like in an animation or a game that
sort of lends itself naturally to being
rerun over and over again again because
that's what it's designed for and it so
continuous re-execution makes a lot of
sense there but you can't continuously
reexecute an entire web app as you're
typing right like what does that even
mean doesn't make much sense um this
whole idea is really predicated on uh
taking a set of code and isolating it
along with its inputs and sort of
mocking away the rest of the world to be
able to do this continuous re-execution
to me that sounds a lot like the process
of writing good unit tests isolating
code mocking things Etc so I think it's
really interesting to look at all this
from the perspective of of unit testing
and tdd and I'll show you an example of
of um what I mean by
that so uh here's a oh no we got the
line WRA issue let me make the font a
little smaller again sorry this the low
resolution is a bit of
a bit of an issue here
but oh it's lower resolution than I
thought
okay
huh yeah it keeps there we go the font's
going to be really small I don't know
why we're getting that problem I think
it's on the other Branch maybe but
anyway so oh it's okay hopefully
hopefully I'll kind of talk to the code
so if it's hard to read hopefully it'll
still make sense this code right here is
is a it's a function that takes an
argument it's a really crappy
implementation of converting a a number
to a string uh and so I can fill in a
hypothetical argument value here to
begin to see uh you know what the code
is doing but I can also fill in an
expected value and you can see that uh
the code is doing the wrong thing it's
actually getting stuck in an infinite
Loop but let's set that aside for a
second second and sort of do uh test
first so I can add a few more test cases
here uh zero is a good Edge case
negative numbers another good Edge case
and uh like I said this code's really
crappy it's failing every test case I
can possibly think of but uh that's fine
let's go back to the first one we tried
the 120 and see if we can actually get a
sense of what's going on here so uh
we're expecting num to converge down to
zero and instead we can see really
easily here that it's actually just
getting into smaller and smaller
floating Point numbers so that's you
know one of these sort of traditional
pitfalls in in JavaScript that integer
division doesn't uh doesn't truncate and
we can really easily fix that with just
adding in a math. floor here oh no it's
doing it again uh let me take some white
space out of the code sorry there we go
so now we can see that uh we're running
three iterations for a three-digit
number that's what we expect the singled
digit case is actually passing already
now but uh if you can see this it's
actually outputting 021 instead of uh
instead of one 120 so it's concatenating
the numbers in the wrong order we're
still getting bad output that's luckily
really easy to fix
two so there we go now we got the two
cases passing fixing the zero is really
easy I can just add in a little extra
thing
here and you get the idea and I I can
make these fixes sort of feeling
confident that I'm not breaking other
stuff because all of these test cases
are being re-executed continuously so if
I did something stupid here like make
making it always return zero you'd
immediately see the feedback that some
of the other test cases had basically
gone red um and one thing this brings to
mind is I think it's it's really
important to sort of begin seriously
thinking about blurring the line between
these sort of one-off test values that
we throw around when we're initially
writing code and getting it up and
running versus the more formal unit
tests that we keep around in the long
run and um one way that we can do that
is to actually you know keep track of
the history of test values that you've
been using like we do here and then
actually generate an initial set of unit
tests for you sort of scaffolding based
on the testing that you've already been
doing so um yeah
so these are just a few ideas I think
there's lots more really awesome ideas
in this space and uh I'm I'm really
looking forward to the day that we can
start using tools like this on on real
world large scale code bases so uh
thanks and back to
NJ it's totally on the wrong Branch for
that sorry about
that yeah all right let's see if I can
get this thing back on the right way
okay is that
good
um Okay cool so
uh so I want to talk a little more about
this idea of sort of live JavaScript so
this is actually a live JavaScript
editing and sort of you know being able
to see results as you edit so how many
people saw Peter vander's talk a few
hours ago oh good bunch of people did
you see you saw your own talk awesome um
and uh so you know he did this great job
showing an approach to this uh you know
there's been a lot of activity in this
space I don't know if you've heard of
light table but those guys are looking
into this I think some of the other sort
of web IDs have been looking into this
as well and it's something that
obviously we've been thinking about too
and um I worked on this part and I
didn't think you needed to see my face
behind me on the screen so I didn't
bother to put a picture of myself in
here but um so I've been thinking about
this and sort of uh looking into an
approach to doing this uh that uh you
know sort of interesting but also a
little bit weird uh and so this is
definitely going to be maybe a little
bit more grotesque than uh you might
want to see but uh hopefully you won't
claw your eyes out all right so uh let
me uh give a little example of what we
have in Brackets today and then I'll
I'll show uh how we're doing how we can
do things differently so right now in
Brackets actually switch different
project here we have a very we have a a
notion of live development right so the
idea is you can go
into uh an application here or a website
and I can open it in the browser uh in
this live development mode and then for
CSS we can do things like you know as
you make edits I can bump the font size
here right like as I'm editing the the
color you can see that it updates the
color in the browser as I'm typing you
know I can do things like get a padding
and whatever right so this is sort of a
it kind of really makes this really
immediate feedback loop between what
you're doing kind of like what what
Peter was showing and it turns out this
is actually pretty easy to do for CSS
because it's declarative right and in
fact the Chrome what we're doing is
we're connecting remotely to the Chrome
developer tools over a websocket and
then we're just pushing new CSS at it
and it knows how to replace that stuff
on the fly now the thing is if you think
about doing that for JavaScript is
actually a lot harder and again if you
saw Peter vander's talk um you know he
talked about some of the challenges
there uh it turns out that Chrome does
some of that stuff already so if you
push a whole new script at Chrome it'll
actually replace function definitions at
least in in some cases uh but it won't
also it won't always work and I'll talk
about some of those edge cases um as I
do this next
demo so uh let me actually switch to a
different build of brackets that has
some different live development stuff in
it this is my prototype code
here
and uh
okay so this is a really stupid app um
basically you click this button and
every time you click the button it shows
a new number or increments a number and
it prints out a message right so um in
this version of the live development
mode what I've done is I've basically
taken the existing Javascript file and
I've instrumented it in such a way that
we can do various kinds of Live code
replacement on it um so again somewhat
similar to some of the stuff Peter had
there so for example I can go here and I
can change this to new message uh and
then without reloading the application
or whatever just pushing a new function
definition you can see that it's showing
the new message here right so I haven't
reloaded the app I haven't saved it or
anything like that um so that's pretty
that's you know one thing you can do um
another thing you can do is you can
actually add new functions here so let
me go ahead and change this so let's I
want to do a little refactoring I want
to make it so that I can you know add
five every time instead of count and I'm
going to do that by defining a new
function so that function is going to
take amount and it's just going to add
that to the count
right okay so now I click on this button
now you can see that it's now by five
right and again I didn't reload the app
I didn't save uh or anything like that
so you know one thing that's interesting
about this case that makes it kind of
hard is that uh you know this new
function I defined and the old function
that it's referring to in the and the
code that it's referring to before like
that stuff was all in this module
closure right so this there's this
closure out here called my logger and
that's what we uh actually use you know
we we put our functions in that to sort
of hide the implementation details and
then we call it from this click handle
so I didn't actually reexecute this
module right because I didn't want to
lose the existing module State I didn't
want to reset this count variable right
we want to keep that state we just want
to add a new function into the closure
and we want that function to be able to
see the current state of what was in
that outer closure but if you don't
reexecute the outer function then how do
you stuff something new into it right
because um this is Javascript and these
closures I mean that's why they're
called closures right they're not
they're supposed to be sealed they're
not supposed to be able to poke new
stuff into an existing closure and
furthermore have the existing stuff in
that closure be able to see new stuff
that you add to it if that old stuff
gets re-executed without re-executing
the whole module to begin with right so
how does that
work sorry was that too like too much a
rhetorical question there okay all right
how does it work all right so let me go
through this little oops sorry um all
right so let's talk about the first
function replacement case and I'm not
going to go into a lot of detail of this
because it's actually quite similar to
the technique I think that uh that Peter
used in his talk so the basic idea is
let's say I start with this code right
this is my script that I type into my
editor right and it says my funk you
know console.log gold message so like I
mentioned before what we do is we before
sending the script to the browser we
actually rewrite it by basically putting
a chunk of extra code into every
function that's in the original script
file and that code looks like this so
you start with the original code which
is here right and then I basically say
okay I'm going to create this table of
function Replacements and so before
every time I enter this function instead
of just executing the code I had
originally written I'm going to look
into that table and see if there's a new
definition and if there is I'm just
going to eval it otherwise I'm going to
use the original function definition and
then once I have that I can just call
funk. apply this comma arguments in
order to make it evaluate the same way
the original function would have right
so it's a pretty straightforward trick
and as again Peter pointed out in his
talk one of the nice things about it is
that if you do this eval in the context
of this function you get all the outer
closure state right all that stuff stays
preserved
right and then when you want to send a
new function over from the editor right
so the user makes an edit and the editor
you just send it over to the browser and
then it um stuffs that back into this
table here okay so the question though
is how do we do this other case right
how do we do this case where you've got
a closure that you don't want to
reevaluate you don't want to rerun this
closure and you have some stuff in it
that gets you know basically defined
when you first execute it right so I
Define a variable I Define a function
that logs that variable and then you
know I as the user I'm in my code editor
and I go and I make some edits and what
I do is I basically introduce this new
function that refers to a variable uh
that was already in the closure and then
also the existing function here I make
call that new function right so there's
two things going on here right both the
new function has to be able to see the
stuff that was in the closure to begin
with this closure instance that already
exists and the old function uh has to be
able to call the new function after its
content gets replaced using the
technique we showed a little while ago
right or in the previous slide this was
that long ago all right so how do we do
it well we use this gr grotesque hack
which is with and so most of you
probably know what with is and you know
mostly that you're not supposed to use
it but basically what it does right if
you're not familiar is it's it was
originally intended as this convenient
feature in JavaScript where you
basically say I have an object with a
bunch of properties on it and like every
time I refer to one of those properties
I want to have to say like some. name
and some object. AG or whatever if you
wrap stuff in a wi block that refers to
that object then what it does is
basically takes all the properties of
that object and puts them in the local
scope so now I can just say name and age
instead of saying some object. name some
object. age so you know like I said it's
this weird convenience feature nobody
really uses it it's actually deprecated
in new versions of of JavaScript um but
and it's partly because it's just weird
right it's like it's injecting all this
random stuff your local scope least
ambiguities and things like that but
this is actually the uh the feature that
makes it so that we can actually use it
to prototype this kind of uh uh
injection of stuff into an existing
closure so how does that work well again
we'll start with the original code right
which was there was this module and it
had this variable and uh this function
in it and so we're going to add a little
more code to it what we're going to do
is we're going to start by just creating
an empty object and we're going to store
it off in a table so we can refer to it
later and then we're going to say with
that empty object do the stuff we were
Define the things that we were going to
Def the module and then take all of the
things that were defined in that module
and stuff them into this scope variable
right into the scope object so because
of the width here all those things
essentially get readed into the local
scope here but that's kind of a noop
right that doesn't do anything because
they were already in the local Scopes
who
cares um but the trick is now when you
want to go to find a new function and
you wanted to see all that stuff and be
seen by all that stuff you can just wrap
it with the same scope object and then
you can copy a pointer to that new
function again into the scope object
right and so now when the new function
executes it sees all of the local stuff
that had pre previously been defined in
the module because it got copied over
into the scope variable right and then
if you re-enter this internal function
right this my funk right this is the
same thing that like that logger
function in the original example right
um then it can actually see the new
function because it got added to the
same scope so basically what with gives
you as a way of exposing and consuming
the lexical scope you know some random
place in your codee uh exposing it as a
dynamic object a dynamic scope that you
can then poke at and and mess with right
all right so big deal like why why would
you even want to do this right like it's
it's weird and confusing and so I think
the reason that I'm interested in it is
because you know if you again if you
went to Peter St he pointed out that
there there's a lot of cases where it
just gets hard to do live JavaScript
development well right like it's one
thing to replace the content of an
existing function that's just going to
get executed again you know like Peter
was saying or if you if you're in like
an an animate Loop or something where
you're just ously re executing it but if
you just add a bit of imperative code
somewhere in a scope where you don't
want to reexecute that whole thing again
you know it's not that easy to do and so
there's just a bunch of these edge cases
and things I think are difficult so what
we really want to do is sort of
prototype this stuff as much as we can
uh using pure JavaScript and using
whatever hacks we need to but ultimately
I think what we really want to do is
Lobby the VM makers you know V8 and and
and JavaScript core and and spider
monkey and all them to basically add
more support for this kind of live
development into the VM you know the
same way that the Java vm's added you
know stuff like hot Cod replacement and
things like that and again you know some
of them are already starting to do this
like there's a little bit of this in V8
already but if we can get them if we can
figure out like what are the right
Primitives that we need in the VMS to
support this style of live development
then you know we could get that stuff
into the VMS and then all of the tooling
you know whether it's brackets or or
light table or whatever could take
advantage of it so let's see
together okay that was pretty nerdy but
it's j conf right so let me skip to one
more thing which is well it's a
different kind of nerdy anyway and I
know I'm running low on time so I'll try
to get through this quick so uh this
last demo is called response and this is
not actually about JavaScript
development this is about CSS
development it was done by this guy Lee
brimo uh who works at Adobe and um so
what I'm going to do real quick is again
for context I'm going to show you some
features that are already in Brackets
and then show you how he's building on
top of that to provide an experience for
responsive design so um if I go back to
my example file here uh one of the
things that we have one of these
features that we have in Brackets is
this idea of inline editing so the idea
is that if I am in like a an HTML tag
for example and I want to see the CSS
associ with that tag inste I having to
like go and dig around my CSS file for
it I can just hit this quick edit key
and what it does is it actually brings
open the associated CSS rule right in
line there so I can just tweak it and
then get out so I can really get into
this sort of mode of I'm just like in my
same file I'm just editing editing stuff
from the CSS and then I can pop out and
we use this idea of inline editing all
over the place like we use it for um you
know for things like colors so like if I
have a color here I can pop open an
inline editor for the color uh if you're
on a CSS property you can get docs from
the web platform docs project and see it
in line and stuff like that so it's just
a sort of UI idea that we had uh for
making it just kind of quicker to work
back and forth between different
contexts so what Le did was he took this
idea and he added to it uh to enable
some responsive design stuff and then
let's talk about what that means so I'm
going to open his responsive design
extension here that air is totally fine
and it's not a bug in my uh in My Demo
um and so the idea here and the the
concept behind this is so you know when
you're doing responsive design stuff uh
you know we''ve got we're starting to
work on on things like tools for
designers to make it easier for them to
to do this stuff we've got this U
project called Reflow that uh We've
started up um for that but if you're a
coder right primarily what you're doing
is you're living in your code all day
but you might want a little help with
sort of visualizing what the results of
your responsive design stuff is going to
be so we built this extension called
response uh and it's built as an
extension to bracket so it's you know
all built again in HTML CSS and
JavaScript and basically what it does is
it gives you this preview of your
website here so it kind of splits open
the brackets window and puts a bunch of
stuff in here and what let you do
essentially is visually define media
query break points and then give you a
really easy way to modify them in code
so like here for example when I get to
about this uh uh this size maybe uh I
want to actually start having the text
be fluid so I can create a media query
breakpoint and then I can use this
inspect mode to select uh an item in the
HTML and let's see if this oh it's not
going to work because the font okay but
you can see that it's selected this
Associated uh container div in my HTML
here and we can use that same quickedit
gesture to see the associated CS Styles
but uh we're in a different mode now
where this is associated with the
current media query so if I now make a
change here to the width it only applies
to that media query so if I make this
back bigger again if I make this bigger
again you can see it's fixed width again
out here and then inside it it's 90%
right so it's basically letting me make
overrides in an individual media query
um you know I could do the same thing
here for this um this grid you know I
want this stuff to not be so spread out
uh in smaller um in smaller uh widths
and so I can go here and I can make that
a fluid width right and so now that
works as I resize the browser window and
then you know I could go ahead and like
make another media query here for you
know this stuff is starting to overflow
so maybe I want to create a new media
query breakpoint and then edit that to
do display n okay so again you know this
isn't necessarily what you do it's not
mobile first and it's not best practice
whatever but gives you the idea of of
what we're uh what the response uh uh
plugin is doing and what it's been doing
all along is I've as I've been making
these edits to what looks like my CSS
tiles it actually wasn't editing the
original CSS what it was doing was
putting those overrides into medoc break
points that were per uh these different
break points that I created visually so
this is a kind of thing where you know
we don't want to build tooling that like
takes over your code and spits out a
bunch of stuff that you don't understand
it's really about kind of giving you a
sort of small amount of tooling that can
Aid your existing coding workflow
without sort of taking it over that's
the idea with
this all right so I think I have like
maybe three more minutes so let me just
go I'll wrap up quickly so four
different demos of some pretty different
things got some JavaScript development
some CSS development um and you know
again you know the idea here is to see
if uh if any of these ideas resonate
with you guys if there things you'd like
to see um or if you have other ideas
that would be cool um I will make a plug
for uh you know brackets as a as a base
for this stuff you when we started
building brackets as a code editor and
we decided to build it in HTML and
JavaScript it was kind of a lark it was
sort of like hey let's see if we can do
this right and we also had this thought
that it's great for a tool to be
implemented in the the same language
that its users use right so that if
you're a person who uses it you can also
hack on it and you can build extensions
to it and all that kind of stuff um but
then there was this more subtle point we
realized kind of later on as we started
finding people building more and more
interesting extensions on top of it that
we hadn't even ever thought of before
like that response extension sort of
came out of the blue one of these days
um and it's really that you know by
analogy I don't know how many of you
have used Eclipse anybody used Eclipse
right so it's this Java IDE and it's
built for Java developers have some of
that same flavor and they spent a bunch
of time thinking about extensibility
right so I mean it's very extensible uh
tool but at the end of the day they were
fundamentally hobbled by the fact that
it was a non- declarative UI stack right
they had to think of an API that would
explicitly let you do certain things so
if you want to add an icon to a toolbar
you want to add a new panel right they
had to think up an API for that but in
the web stack you don't have to do that
it's like that guy you know the guy who
wrote that response thing like he just
hacked a bunch of stuff into the Dom and
it just worked right we didn't have to
give him permission we didn't have to
figure out what the right API was going
to be before he did it now that's not
saying that you never need clean apis
and you never have to think about expens
ability we've thought about it a lot too
but our philosophy is really you know
put the paths where people want to walk
as opposed to like let's try to figure
out every possible thing somebody might
want to do in advance and so we found
that at least we think that makes
brackets a really good sandbox for this
kind of experimentation with developer
tooling so if you have ideas for
developer tooling that you want to try
out um you know in the context of a code
editor uh we'd like to invite you to
play in the sandbox too so we're
github.com Adobe brackets that's the
main GitHub repo if you just want to
download a be able to try it out you can
get that at download. brackets.io and um
these slides are online at this URL here
and I am NJ and not web safe and that's
my talk thank
you oh and I forgot to say uh if anybody
wants to come up I have some bracket 3D
printed brackets logos for you for
people who who want them uh I think
we're kind of running over so I don't
know if we should take questions or oh
there's a break okay is there are there
any questions while while I'm
here yeah
the live development right now yeah that
that only works with chrome because
we're talking to the Chrome debugging
tools currently um but obviously you
know Mozilla is starting to have they
have the remote deing protocol and
things like that so we're planning to
hook that up as
well
uhhuh
y yeah we haven't we haven't started
working on it officially we've got some
prototypes I mean the main thing is
where do you want your code to be stored
right it has to be in some back end so
we've got like a prototype of running
against Dropbox as a back end just sort
of as a proof of concept the intention
is eventually we'll basically abstract
it so you could have any one of a number
of backends um but we haven't done the
work to actually make that official yet
so we're hoping to do that I don't know
can we say sort of by the we're hoping
by the end of the
year
uhhuh yeah no yeah so the question was
could we support Source Maps um for
these things where we're doing all this
crazy instrument of JavaScript we
certainly could like I said this is just
kind of a hack prototype it's not sort
of cleanly packaged up the same way that
Peter's stuff was so um but yeah that's
definitely what you would want to do if
you were going to go with this
instrumentation based approach for
sure other questions oh
yeah
yeah no we definitely have to do that so
for which part were you talking about
were you talking about like the live
JavaScript replacement stuff or were you
talking about um some of the other stuff
yeah I mean that's that's the other
thing I was right is that basically when
you deal with real world JavaScript you
have all of these things you have to
worry about right you have to worry
about people putting stuff in modules
and asynchronous loading and stuff like
that so like I said that's part of the
hard problems that we have to think
through this is just like the first like
tiny slice of what we would have to
think through to get this to work in
kind of a real world production
environment where you actually want it
to
work anything
else all right thanks a
lot